kaddoumi certain sur les deux plateaux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
d'être humain
wimereux
et
guy martin
[Musique]
je suis dadou ise et pourtant je mange
là d'où je dors dazhou je fais pipi
dazhou je fais tout dazhou j'aime dazhou
ça va mon frérot d'amour qu'est ce que
t'es frais merci d'être avec nous il
faut grâce à ce signal on essaye de te
suit de suivre la cadence
moubarak est marié et j'ai deux et je te
fais confiance
j'ai pas besoin d'attendre plus
longtemps je sais il est temps de
partager mon sens est déjà fait
or d'airé
au rang des rêves
et ont déroulé
nadja tu quitteras dénoue pas
franchement ouais franchement
franchement c'est un exemple de réussite
c'est enfin non c'est dingue c'est
dingue ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il a créé
et en plus moi je suis un grand grand
j'ai vraiment aimé la collaboration avec
l'école j'étais sur thalys
mais c'est un truc de fait à dieu mais
l'appel à l'époque école parce que moi
j'ai aimé chez métro je suis un grand
fan des connes donc quand j'ai vu la
collaboration en plus j'ai vraiment sûr
qu'il fait car tu veux une crête
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'ai deux cadeaux est-ce que tu prends
une crêpe ou un cadeau mystère à un
cadeau mystère mystère l anomie certain
sur les jeux de plateau
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
banda lous sylviane de platine face à
carton tadjou veut la paix la nouvelle
app enivre ces boissons qui hockey la
question géraldine oui une vie de ces
ralentis je suis pas
qui est ce que tu kiffes le plus entre
gims annonce est ce que tu me kiffe plus
que kim sang fait répond par oui ou non
rien d'autre je souris ou non oui
[Applaudissements]
maccioni avec un corps impoli les hommes
sont sortis tiers raté
les approcher avec le toute humilité
mieux médecin balotelli m'en veux un peu
mieux pas d'amis je suis bien
[Musique]